the cell and counter-offensive goes on
artillery pound Russian positions a few
miles away
[Music]
this flat land leading towards the city
of Kirsten is a battlefield dominated by
artillery and Rockets
it's why the counter-attack is moving
more slowly down here than the Ukrainian
efforts in the North
tank battalions maneuver towards the
front line to support Infantry
behind them the main defensive line is
held by miles of dug in and camouflage
tank and artillery positions
their job is to combat any sudden
Russian fight back
they load their tanks with personalized
shells from ecolo to moscows it says a
gift from ukrainians to Russians
but this offensive comes at a cost in
Lost lives Medics prepare for their
shift rescuing people injured at the
front
the casualties they say can on some days
be very high
the reason is simple the Russians knew
they were coming
up uh
Sky News is allowed to travel to the
defensive position supporting the
counter-attack
the drive through the farmlands of the
South is eerie and dangerous the supply
routes are constantly attacked
it's why anything that shows where we
are could be targeted by the Russian
forces well there are soldiers
absolutely everywhere but such as the
level of secrecy about this
counter-offensive that the military
won't be filmed and they won't let us go
to any of their positions we're only
about 14 miles or so from the
front line of the offense this is the
main defensive position for the
Ukrainian position as I say it's uh
they're trying to really keep a wraps on
on what exactly is happening as they try
to get into Curson City
it's remarkable but some civilians
always stay in these towns at the center
of the fighting
area commander major Sergey sahotsky
originally from Crimea keeps an eye out
for people like 60 year old Luba
we asked her what the counter-offensive
was like it smells like Victory she said
like all ukrainians is optimistic but
the noises from the Kremlin are ominous
this conflict could so easily escalate
and that means nobody here is safe
Ramsey Sky News Southern Ukraine